juicy tasty
tasty
tasty
so delicious
you
God
you
you see
but you see
juicy
you see
you see
you
you
juicy
solar brush tasty
so delicious
juicy
you
you said
you
juicy
did you see
tasty
tasty
soda crush
why
juicy
and you said
juicy
did you see
tasty
tasty
you
soda brush
why
Oh
tasty
tasty
divine
you
I'm
tasty
tasty soda crush
you
jam
and tasty
you
divine
juicy
divine
juice
tasty
juicy solo crush
do fine
bubblegum juicy juicy
juicy
juicy
Solar crush
tasty
so da
see
juicy
tasty
25
solo
you
you
you
25
tasty
juicy
you
juicy
juicy
juice
so delicious juicy
you
you
tasty
Solar crush
you
you
frosting
juice
juicy
solo lucious
you
juicy
juicy
so delicious
juicy
Solar crush
divine
you
you
hey guys Pete peppers here and this is a
commentary walkthrough for candy crush
soda level 8 45 pause the video here I
want to talk about it for a second what
the one thing that I noticed a couple
episodes ago was that they you know the
hard levels and so to ablate they seemed
to sort of have a run of themes right
word but it seems like there's a certain
each episode has like similar hard
levels so when I noticed it it was all
like honey levels and this one it seems
like the hardest ones are all have the
thick ice and you know it seems like
mostly the way they make these levels
hard is they you know figure out what
the normal amount of moves would be for
it and just take a couple away so you
know you can figure out how to do it for
the most part but you're going to have
to just get it you know get a super run
on it in order to get it done without
using any of the Boosters and probably
part of the reason why they're getting
harder is because they give more
boosters away so they expect that you
have them and if you don't you can just
play you know the fishing tournament or
bubblegum hill or whatever it is so it's
kind of a pain for me to make videos I
always like to make no boosters I don't
really enjoy earning the Boosters as
much just so that I can get through them
I like to just have a level that I can
beat and I think a lot of people play
that way and but a lot of other people
like to be able to earn the booster so
it's just a matter of taste I guess so
this level 8 45 was a really hard one
and took a lot of tries to get through
for me but it was very similar to level
8 30 which was the first hard one in the
episode so the one thing that I came up
with whenever I was working on writing
some tips and things was you know
you can you can get a lot of stuff to
happen in this but you just can't get
through it without running out of moves
or using some of your boosters if you
can't set up a colouring candy plus
color bomb combo so what I'm doing now
is I'm just trying to look for places
where I can make a bomb you know looking
for you know spots like this thread here
below the fish where you have part of
the bomb already in place and then
moving the pieces in or like the blue on
this side you know just moving moving
the places into to see if I can set it
up and it's it's pretty tough to do
because you know you don't have the
whole board to work with so you know
obviously in the beginning you can you
can use there's some you know like
wrapped candies and the ice and things
like that that you can use especially if
you make them into rat plus stripe
combos to clear some ice I'll that
that's can be helpful but in all the
times I played it to beat this a beauty
twice once for the regular video and
once for this all the times I played it
I just didn't get it I never could get
rid of enough of the layers of ice if I
didn't set up that combo so here you
know I can drop the yellow and make a
bomb so I'll do that I'm not really
going to use the bomb for anything else
and I actually got a good drop here so I
can mix these together but let's let's
look at what happens here you know we
have various different layers of
thickness of the ice and whenever I make
this match it's going to clear it all
off and what another thing that makes
this level hard is if you if you if you
remove the squares piece by piece the
coils underneath come up so that kind of
takes it long or even to get to the next
next layer down so of course I'm going
to make this combo here i'm not going to
worry about anything else and just going
to see the
that the ice just gets completely
cleared out so from there you know we
can we have 16 moves left so we you know
we can likely you know finish things off
without too much of a problem the coils
do make it hard even if you do get the
if you get the combo but not that many
moves left you know it can still be
tough to finish it off so you know as
far as tips go for this I you know I i
would say that just just work to try to
set that set that combo up and it's
tough it'll get frustrating at times
especially what I noticed happened a lot
the first time I was playing it was that
I would you know set up the set up the
match to drop you know the final pieces
in the place for a bomb and you know
something would fall from the top and
mess it up or something like that so it
was always a real pain but once you get
that cleared out it's not too bad so
work on that and hopefully you get that
soon a couple other things you know you
can use you can you know you can make
other combos in the beginning to just
sort of clear the board out like
sometimes if you have a bomb set in
there just using it on a color is ok
because that'll that'll clear up all you
know clear out some space to get a
cascade and might set up a better
opportunity but you know you don't want
to you don't want to play around too
much because you do need a few you do
need a few of the moves left to clear
out all the all the coils at the end so
I hope this will help I'll put it in the
the tips I just wrote up and make sure
that you give the video a like if you
find it useful and subscribe to my
channel check out the guide on the
website I'll put the link here in the
video and we'll talk to you soon thanks